okay. Some very interesting discussions happening
on the David Pakman show, reddit@davidpakman.com
slash R E. D. D. I. T. the first one is from
a user named nostalgic Sans who says, no disrespect,
but can we truly expect these old candidates
to even survive for years? Trump, Biden Sanders
are all late seventies.
I don't see them living another four to eight
years. Sanders had a heart attack. Trump's
a walking cholesterol medicine advertisement
and Biden is seeming very weird with his GAF.
Someone also adding Bloomberg had stents.
Um, while he, uh, had had stents put in. Warren
is no spring chicken. So listen, I don't believe
it is ages to consider this. And the truth
is, when you look at life expectancy at birth,
Bernie was born in 1941. Biden was born in
1942. Trump was born in 1946 life expectancy
for people born in those years was between
70 and 70. Uh, 72 when you account for. So
life expectancy at birth tends to be lower
because it has to account for some people
who don't make it out of infancy. Life expectancy
once age 65 for people born in the years that
these folks were born in is somewhere between
12 and a half and 13 more years.
So if you in a very detached way, look at
the data, uh, these are reasonable concerns.
Now, the truth is that in the United States,
economic class has a lot to do with life expectancy.
And so when you get to these numbers, 77 78,
you know, once you account for already being
reaching the age of 65, it is probably quite
stratified based on your income level and,
and economic class. And of course, Bernie
Biden and Trump are all doing well economically.
I don't believe it is aged just merely to
ask these questions. Um, and, and I'm interested
in hearing more from folks, uh, about it.
Another user. Phylo 1927 posted an article
from the Washington post called, uh, or, or
arguing that an article from the Washington
post points out that Trump has no clue what
to do in a disaster. Referring of course to
coronavirus. I am increasingly concerned not
about coronavirus in the abstract, but specifically
about Donald Trump's ability to actually manage
something like a massive outbreak or pandemic.
And we're going to get to it in more detail
later today. I know a lot of you are worried
about it because of the number of posts about
it on the David Pakman Reddit, the number
of emails I'm getting from you, the number
of tweets I'm getting from you. I agree. Trump
has no clue how to deal with a disaster. Remember
in Puerto Rico after the hurricanes, he went
and shot rolls of toilet paper like basketballs
and had no idea what to do. Um, it's, it's,
it's a major problem and we're going to address
it more in a moment. Lastly from the Reddit
user, Dennis Hopper says, South Carolina is
a turning point, arguing that South Carolina
is going to be a place that, um, has two outcomes.
Either Bernie wins and becomes the favorite
to win, not just a plurality, but a majority
of the delegates or Biden wins. Gaining delegates
and taking momentum away from Bernie, muddying
the waters heading into super Tuesday.
I am less, uh, decided that South Carolina
will be a turning point. Um, I, I think that
because there's only two days between South
Carolina and super Tuesday, I think super
Tuesday is the turning point and I believe
that after super Tuesday, we will see either
a very clear path to a contested or brokered
convention and negotiated convention because
more people will have delegates. We might
Michael Bloomberg, we'll have delegates after
super Tuesday. Maybe Tom Stier will, that's
one scenario. Or Bernie will clean up on super
Tuesday and it will a very much look like
nobody will be able to catch them. I believe
super Tuesday is the turning point. Join the
discussion@davidpakman.com slash Reddit nearly
18,000. Can you imagine nearly 18,000 of our
viewers and listeners subscribed free? Of
course, there's no charge to participate,
no entry fee at all. Um, participating in
the David Pakman show, Reddit.